good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp 2003
object class
thalmiel
special containment procedures
scp-2003 is contained at armed site 47 a
type 4 restricted zone in accordance
with type 4 protocols personnel assigned
to scp-2003 research security and
maintenance must undergo expanded
background check procedures as well as
successfully pass a hoiberg causewa
causality questionnaire access to
scp-2003 itself is limited to xn shepard
project participants with prior approval
from the director of site 47.
all information regarding determinative
sets elevated probability events
designated magnifier individuals and the
xn shepard program is classified and
accessible only by the director of site
47 057 and those personnel read into
scp-2003 security protocols
observations of designated indicator
data deviating significantly from
determinative set xn parameters are to
be reported immediately to the director
of site 47 and treated as a level 5
existential threat emergency response
event
description
scp-2003 is an apparatus allowing a
limited degree of travel to and from
periods of time in advance of those
encountered in the normal course of
space-time as understood by mainstream
science
scp-2003 was designed and built by the
foundation over a 25-year period using
technology derived from research into
scp
scp
and scp
while the technical capabilities and
design specifications of scp-2003 are
well documented and reproducible if
necessary the scientific and anomalous
principles behind its functionality are
not understood at this time
upon activation
scp-2003 is capable of transporting a
living entity contained within its
central chamber to a point coterminous
with its present location in physical
space but located in a future time
period the amount of time into the
future traveled by the subject is
related to the amount of energy input
into scp-2003 an approximate estimate of
3500 kilowatt hours in order to send a
subject seven months into the future has
been documented however this
relationship becomes unpredictable at
higher energy levels
subjects using
scp-2003 will exist in the time period
to which they have traveled for a
duration ranging between 15 and 38 weeks
before spontaneously returning to the
time period of origination at a point
coterminous with their present location
for safety purposes a secure location
has been established for operatives to
use while waiting for return to their
time of origin operatives must report
subsequent to experiencing 98 days after
scp-2003 activation
while scp-2003 enables chronological
travel for living subjects the
activation process has proven severely
damaging to most types of animal and
plant tissue the only exception
documented to date has been tissue
related to the animal nervous system as
a result personnel designated for
scp-2003 travel must be prepared
accordingly see additional documentation
for details
testing has shown that under current
conditions
scp-2003 remains functional and under
foundation control through december of
2348
addendum 2003 a general results of
scp-2003
research
initial deployment of scp-2003 began in
1995
using modified personnel to observe
future conditions and events the purpose
of these deployments was to confirm the
nature of travel using
scp-2003 and if possible collect data
allowing the foundation to better
mitigate future anomalous phenomena the
results of these initial exploratory
missions demonstrated several crucial
principles for understanding observation
of future
events data collected using scp-2003
is imprecise
early exploratory missions yielded
copious amounts of data regarding what
appeared to be future events however
subsequent observation has established
that these observations are not entirely
predictive for instance while collected
data allowed foundation assets to
prevent a major security breach of scp
at site 19 in 1997 a catastrophic
earthquake originating off the coast of
the western united states observed
directly by several field agents using
scp-2003
failed to occur as predicted in 1999 as
more data has been collected
meta-analysis has properly
contextualized observations and has
assigned a probability of occurrence for
major events in the future
certain individuals appear to affect
causality disproportionately as
foundation cataloging of possible future
events increased following the
completion of more exploratory missions
certain events were deemed to be
undesirable for the foundation's mission
early attempts to influence these events
met with mixed success while
manipulation and or elimination of some
individuals achieved mission goals other
foundation attempts to influence events
failed to alter outcomes at all even
when several actors deemed it to be
essential or liquidated meta-analysis
has determined that in some cases the
actions or indeed the very existence of
individuals with no discernible relation
to major events sometimes in regions
thousands of kilometers away have
profound and immediate impacts on these
events since this discovery research
staff has maintained a database of these
individuals
few cohesive futures are tolerable to
the continued beneficial existence of
humanity while observed conditions
exhibit a tendency towards variation
upon each exploratory mission a number
of loosely consistent timelines have
been observed and cataloged in
foundation databases as determinative
sets most determinative sets consist of
a collective future that either renders
earth unsuitable for human civilization
and in some cases life in total or
results in conditions directly inimical
to the well-being of most of humanity
the reasons for the relative paucity of
long-term survival scenarios if they
exist are unknown at this time as is any
connection to the steadily increasing
observation of anomalous phenomena
documented across the foundation
addendum 2003 b preparation of personnel
for use
due to the nature of scp-2003's effects
on human anatomy special preparations
must be made in order to properly outfit
personnel for chronological travel in a
condition suitable for both survival and
ability to carry out mission objectives
because of the sensitive nature of tasks
necessary during scp-2003 missions
d-class have been deemed unsuitable
subjects
preference for scp-2003 subject
recruitment is to be given to personnel
nearing or past official retirement age
in cases where personnel have been
diagnosed with terminal illness that
does not impair neurological or
cerebrospinal function preference may
also be granted personnel volunteering
for scp-2003 travel are to be moved to
the tier vi pay scale for the duration
of their assignment any survivors are
entitled to an elevated benefits package
distributed through normal clandestine
channels
prior to outfitting selected personnel
are to undergo extended sensory
deprivation training concurrent with
training in simulated environments
analogous to those experienced by
occupants of the
xx890v life function and observation
system or lfo for short during this
period personnel must undergo a
prophylactic course of antidepressants
and antipsychotics as overseen by
medical staff
upon completion of training regimens
personnel are to have all brain tissue
nerves and associated nervous system
structures surgically removed and
transplanted into the xx890v
lfo system all usable organs are to be
harvested afterward per medical
protocols
current guidelines authorize the xx890v
lfo system and occupant for four uses of
scp-2003
when not engaged on missions personnel
are to be kept in an induced coma state
concurrent with research establishing 18
months as the median time period before
communications and feedback from xx89tv
lfo occupants become agitated and
incomprehensible
the nature of the xx890v lfo system is
to remain classified and accessible to
only senior personnel
addendum 2003 c
overview of xn shepard program
memorandum
2 armed site 47 director
from 057
regarding determinative set
xn up to this point all attempts at
future intervention using scp 2003 have
been limited in scope and scatter shot
in nature
i have seen the wisdom in this approach
it is informed by painstaking
contingency planning and risk benefit
evaluation
the last 18 months of reports however
have promised if we are bold enough to
seize the initiative
we may have found a way out here
the price though
there's always a price as you well know
consider this a note of an official
change in policy
as of today all efforts at intervention
are now aimed at bringing about and
preserving xn designated magnifier
individuals associated with xn are to be
protected from undue interference at the
expense of all other priorities
in particular nuru diagony must be
allowed to die in the manner most
observations have predicted for her
if anything at all changes in that
regard
make it happen
i trust you're familiar enough with the
rest of the determinative sets to
understand why we are going this way
one more thing
all communications and i mean all with
anyone outside of site 47 are to be
cleared and rooted through my office
addendum 2003 d listing of known
determinative sets
preferred option
designation xn
description currently documented reality
society continues along established
foundation projections regarding
economic trends environmental factors
and social upheaval anomalous activity
continues to manifest mostly consistent
with present rates consensus reality
maintained successfully until 83345 more
a previously untracked asteroid 22
kilometers in diameter collides with
earth in january of 2349 killing most of
humanity immediately and rendering the
planet unsuitable for sustained human
existence
notes c addendum 2003 c
other documented determinative sets
designation xb
description development of society
continues in manner similar to xn until
april 23rd 2017
when a gamma ray burst originating from
the vicinity of
hd188753 directly strikes earth the
burst lasts for two minutes and 38
seconds and kills all known forms of
life
notes researchers directly observing
this scenario at the time of the
gamma-ray burst was the only known
living being to survive the event and
was able to continue collecting data
until his return 52 days later study of
use of xx890v lfo system for high
radiation environments pending
designation xe
description the election of sir william
and twissel as prime minister of new
zealand in 2049 combined with the birth
of an unnamed infant boy in the ahul
province turkmenistan on the same day
lead to an escalating chain of events
culminating in a society destroying
nuclear exchange between the nations of
israel and greater indonesia in 2058 all
foundation attempts to interfere with
either individual merely result in the
date of the nuclear exchange occurring
sooner
notes in all permutations of this set
widespread public knowledge of the
foundation occurs precisely 86 days
before the detonation of nuclear weapons
designation xh
description between the years of 2023
and 2034 world governments approach
global affairs at a radically increased
level of cooperation due to the onset of
a highly virulent influenza epidemic
that kills approximately 1.4 billion
worldwide throughout the 2040s and 2050s
many long-standing ethnic conflicts are
resolved through the intervention of
multilateral organizations endemic
poverty and hunger in areas such as
sub-saharan africa and the indian
subcontinent are substantially decreased
and large-scale projects mitigating sea
level rise are completed throughout
coastal regions on july 29th 2059 the
entire population of earth spontaneously
vanishes along with all known animal
life with no observed return within
observational range
designation xj
description an entity later confirmed to
be an exact duplicate of dr masako
koizumi one of the original researchers
responsible for scp
prior to its containment appears within
an inner security perimeter at armed
site 47 on april 1 2011. the entity
requests that dr koizumi's scheduled
euthanization elsewhere within the
facility be cancelled immediately as scp
was not functional at the time of
established containment the means by
which the entity is able to make this
request are unknown and presumed to
occur in the future however due to the
establishment of k-failsafe protocol 12
the request is impossible for foundation
personnel to comply with resulting in an
alpha 8-type temporal paradox this
series of events repeats for an
uncountable number of instances
resulting in the eventual collapse of
space-time as understood by humanity
notes this scenario was ultimately
averted by staff sedating the duplicate
of dr koizumi placing it into an xx890v
lfo platform and transporting it in
scp-2003
using all available energy temporal
complications from this action are
unknown but presumably do not
materialize prior to 2349
designation xo
description anomalous phenomena began
increasing in frequency by orders of
magnitude beginning in 2037. the
foundation comprehensively loses
capabilities to protect consensus
reality by 2039 and world civilization
undergoes a period of chaos and upheaval
millions die in spontaneous riots and
mass suicides become commonplace
throughout the world numerous messianic
religious movements quickly form and
contribute greatly to civil conflict and
inter nissan warfare by the mid-2040s
several sects and remnants of national
governments successfully weaponize
various anomalous phenomena and humanity
is wiped out by 2048 with the exception
of a small group of survivors sheltering
in the remnants of site 104 all contact
with this group is lost upon their
discovery of wing k
in site 104
notes due to the open nature of
anomalous phenomena in this scenario
data collected is the most comprehensive
of any determinative set as agent is
able to work openly and unimpeded
designation xr
description the population of homo
ignotus long estimated by foundation
operatives to be approximately 500
individuals increases overnight to
approximately 8 million individuals in
2015. a short violent struggle ensues
between the combined forces of the
foundation and h ignotus with all means
of resistance to the newly ascendant h
ignotus population systematically
destroyed within three days humanity is
then
researchers currently have divergent
theories as to whether this
determinative set is predictive of the
intentions of the known hygnotis
population with current theories of
and
being supported the most
notes data expunged
designation
xs
description determinative set xs
proceeds in a manner similar to xn until
an indeterminate date in 2019 when armed
site 47 and all knowledge of scp-2003 is
apparently lost to the foundation
researcher is detained by the xs version
of the foundation during an
observational mission in 2022 and held
as an scp-classified phenomenon until
her return
researcher is detained by excess
foundation personnel at point of entry
upon commencement of her next
observational mission and returns with
no retrievable data and portions of her
brain tissue removed no further
information on determinative set xs is
available
notes level 4 security access only
designation xu
description on february 17 2026 contrary
to all astronomical models and
understanding of both classical and
quantum mechanics the sun suddenly
collapses into a black hole despite not
meeting commonly understood mass
thresholds for triggering such an event
despite the almost immediate cooling of
earth and all other planets in the solar
system to approximately minus 270
degrees celsius and the elimination of
all other forms of life humans are
unable to die maintaining consciousness
despite the lack of continuing
biological functions and almost total
cessation of molecular movement
notes this determinative set is a subset
of previously designated set xt
xt was a future in which a single
totalitarian regime had assumed control
over the planet and targeted various
subversive organizations for elimination
focusing on foundation personnel in
particular foundation researchers
attempted to avert this scenario by
sending three identified individuals
from south korea into orbit on the
international space station
xu resulted
designation xw
description being strongly resembling
human-sized animate versions of scp
manifest in most major population
centers on august 13 2019 rather than
causing alarm these beings quickly
become accepted by humanity after
offering major advances in medical
science energy production crop
cultivation and the arts by the close of
2022 thousands of people willingly join
an experimental program to combine the
consciousness of multitudes of humans
into a singular entity in 2024 a fully
mature human believed to possess a mind
composed of the transferred
consciousness of approximately 134 000
people is created by these beings this
human is then confined to a cell left
with only automatically dispensed
supplies of food and water and sealed
off from all outside contact all other
humans are systematically exterminated
by the end of 2024
notes the last two personnel sent to
observe determinative set xw agent and
researchers
failed to return to time of origin and
are listed missing in action at this
time
designation xx
description an undiscovered protist
unidentified in the observed timeline
designated nephroisis spora irani by
foundation researchers undergoes a
geometric increase in population due to
what is presumed to be a recently
developed adaptation allowing it to
survive in almost all aqueous
environments and irani proves adept at
moving into and surviving in human
nervous tissue initiating a disorder
similar to toxoplasmosis
that causes humans to develop a
monomaniacal fontness for phenutreya
nigriventer brazilian wondering spider
by 2028 almost 85 percent of the human
population has been infected and most of
society's resources are reordered
towards the preservation and breeding of
pnig reventor unaffected individuals are
detained and in most cases interred in
penigriventer breeding facilities in an
attempt to provide additional food
sources for the specimens due to the
singular worldwide focus on production
and maintenance of spider populations
crop failures and infrastructure
degradation becomes systemic and global
famine results in the death of
approximately 6 billion persons in the
2030s notes research is ongoing into
possible anomalous causes behind the
increased prevalence of the n irani and
or the nature of its function as a
pathogen
designation x z description earth has
been completely depopulated large
facilities have been constructed in the
center of all sites a former major
cities capable of enabling instantaneous
travel over an immense distance to a
point determined by post-observation
analysis to be somewhere in the vicinity
of the hydra supercluster subsequent
observers were authorized to enter these
facilities and were apparently
transported to an earth analogous biome
planet with a functioning human
civilization in each case observers
transported to this location were
immediately detected by residents of
this planet while residents choose to
forego any communication with observers
each observer was subsequently escorted
through the selected locations of the
society encountered on this planet
encompassing large public works projects
monuments museums and other culturally
significant locations the human
civilization encountered in the hydra
supercluster is apparently advanced by
modern standards and lacking in many of
the most commonly identified factors
negatively affecting extant societies
this civilization has persisted past the
range of observation thus far indicating
ongoing survival
notes further investigation authorized
under xn shepard reevaluation of
preferred option pending
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
the morrigan
professor puffer
retalias
karim el ashmuy
ala treon
your local fish man
derivative
talk of villagers
gabriel hawkins
nate the klein
lost boy
african submarine vore
seventy
kristoff kozak zlezak
hms lily
the almighty fish gav the clumsy
containment specialist
pure osmium
scio dio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbin
longinus
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the vulgan
thank you
[Music]
you